وعندما ننتقل الى مكان جديد او نقضي بعض
الوقت مع صديق لديه لهجه مميزه غالبا ما
تتسلل الينا اللهجه تدريجيا دون ان نلاحظ
ذلك دراسه حديثه اجراها باحثه جامعه
بنسلفانيا كشفت كيفيه انتشار لهجات بين
الاشخاص مثل العدوان دراسه كشفت عن ظاهره
تعرف بالتقارب الصوت والتي تحدث عندما
يبدا الناس في تقليد نطق الاخرين عند
التحدث الى اشخاص بلهجه مختلفه الدراسه
خلصت لان لهجات مختلفه تنتشر مثل العدوى
من خلال الاختلاط وترتبط بدرجه الانخراط
في المهام والعمل فكل ما كان الفرد اكثر
الانخراطا فيما يفعله مع الاخرين كان اكثر
عرضه لالتقاط الى هاجاتهم وبالنسبه للهجات
العربيه فقط اظهر استطلاع للراي اجرته
مؤسسه
ان اللهجه الجزائريه هي اصعب لهجات
العربيه
الليبيه فيما تعتبر اللهجه المصريه اسهل
واكثر اللهجات العربيات في العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اختلاف اللهجات العربيه في العالم العربي
واقع المفروض ونحن جمعناها لكم تحت سقف
واحد في قناه العربيه فلنتعرف على اي هذه
اللهجات اصعب العراقيه انا تونسيه عراقيه
انا تونسيه وفلسطينيه انا من الاردن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا تونسيه وفلسطين ورح اقرا مثل باللهجه
العراقيه الي ما يعرف يرقص
انا عراقيه وحاول احكي كلمه بالجزائري
[موسيقى]